out of the blue in his 28th year sac
began to develop panic attacks at the
most inconvenient moments at an office
presentation or a business networking
event he'd feel extraordinarily anxious
get an urge to run away and often need
to find bathroom very fast it started to
become hugely debilitating for Zack who
worked in a rather unforgiving
fast-moving tech company in San
Francisco a friend recommended a
therapist it was pretty weird to find
himself on a therapists couch he'd never
had much time for the idea of therapy
the first thing the therapist told him
was that here in this room he could
panic just about as much as he liked and
it wasn't going to be a problem he could
run away faint be safe as all fine buy
her that helped immensely they began
talking about what some of these panic
attacks might have in common it was
actually deeply refreshing to talk to
someone who didn't keep interrupting or
shifting the agenda someone had just
kept the focus on what he was feeling
and tried to decode it for him
something struck Zack as he spoke the
panic he felt had a habit of arising
whenever there were expectations on him
whenever people were waiting for him to
be impressive clever or decisive in some
way and there was a chance to make
himself look like a fool or a jerk
It was as though one part of him was
deliberately undermining and sabotaging
the other whenever there was an
opportunity to shine or triumph if it
carries on like this I'll have no option
but to head back home and live with my
parents
remarked Zack darkly one day towards the
end of a session that turned out to be
the start of a very fruitful line of
discussion Zack had grown up in rural
Minnesota his father was a roofer
neither his parents had been to college
he'd been the bright one who'd flown the
nest the gap between Zack and his
parents was now huge he might earn in
one year would his father earned in five
the more Zack told a therapist about his
background but more he realized what a
burden of guilt he was carrying around
with him the guilt that success was
leading him to exceed his parents in a
way that was at once exciting and
properly frightening Zack wanted success
but being successful was also
threatening to separate him
from the two people he felt the greatest
step to the panic attacks seemed like a
devilish way to stay faithful to his
parents it was like an act of
self-sabotage calculated to protect the
parents and especially the father who
had some competitive envious sides to
his otherwise warm nature all this from
the risks of humiliation it was as
though in one part of his mind
Zach didn't believe he could be both an
impressive adult and a loyal son
discovering this about himself helped
Zach a lot gradually the symptoms
lessened he learned how to understand
himself for wanting not to have the life
his parents had had and to forgive
himself for looking for something better
at the same time he accepted that he
could remain loving and admiring of many
qualities his parents had and that those
around him in the tech scene often
didn't Zack continued in therapy for a
year the attacks stopped completely
without any need for medication It was
as if part of his mind had been listened
to and no longer felt the need to ruin
Zach's life in order to be heard
recently Zach was invited to address a
conference of 2000 delegates the speech
went perfectly the School of Life offers
therapy in person or over Skype click
here for details
you